in the jungle some of the biggest
problems come from the smallest of
creatures tiny man-eaters can strike
without ever being noticed until they've
had their fill this researcher has been
infected with a chigga flea a parasite
more commonly known as a sand flea or a
chigger the flea latches on to an
unprotected foot digs in and feet it may
sound unpleasant but the damage is
minimal unless it's a female ready to
reproduce a pregnant chick er
burrows in under the skin within a
couple of weeks her one millimeter frame
balloons into a pea sized ball of pain a
swollen lesion develops that makes
movement difficult but if the lesion
gets infected then a painful nuisance
becomes a serious medical problem severe
cases can lead to tetanus gangrene and
auto amputation
so if underneath your skin is a chigger
that's expecting what should you do
a Burnet be cut it out or C pull it out
the correct answer is B cut it out
[Music]
burning causes as much damage to you as
to the chigger pulling it out can
rupture the egg sac and increase the
chances of infection cutting out the
entire lesion removes every part of the
weed but don't stop there clean the
wound thoroughly and apply antibiotics
and that's how you survive a chigger
infestation
[Music]